[Music]
you have I'm gonna tell you something
real douchey my water was in a glass
bottle yours was in the plastic oh
thanks a lot
so we have cancer and she's go okay just
a single jerk not nice man see if you
can tell the news or anything no I
haven't even sipped it yet do you have
any stomach clues I mean it's going
around up
well you guys are moms where they're
like touching and then are know this is
to get real graphic oh god I am when
we're breastfeeding oh Jesus cream Sanji
or breast milk is an antibiotic your
baby ends at Lennon think remember yeah
we may we've gotten into what we talked
about
well the miracle of breast milk yeah
because you're making me about meconium
the last time I suppose this is where we
are big America's like oh no you don't
want to hear that
city literally though sometimes I look
at mine in the mirror like some large
American naturals usually mean my life
like I gotta make the most of it you got
like a natural breast job oh I got
enlarged by apparently when you're done
nursing they end up looking like a
deflated cornucopia or like a wrung out
athletic sock and so that's and I can
see that in my future
a sock full of like refried beans your
babies like why does it res no taste
like 375 I'm so excited to be sitting
here with to my absolute favorite people
comedians writers performers improvisers
and just all-around wonderful women do
they oversell it
Lennon Parham and just st. Claire
Jessica st. Claire we're close so I say
Justin yeah we're pretty Jessica's here
this actually says this on the card it
says you guys have woman crushes on each
other uh-huh yeah we're friends means
yeah right we're soap no it's true we
are so close that we might as well be
lesbians buddy curious hmm bye-bye
curious but I curious that's great
that'll sweep the nation once I had to
let Lennon see my ass crack why I always
have to and I did I did have to there
was something there was a situation
happening down there I don't know what
it was something something of a rash
nature and I had kept it from my husband
for like three weeks and then I was like
you just back out of the room yeah yeah
weird it I would like crap walk back
just like dude let's get her back there
was a good
like a pelvic thrust yeah I had to show
Lenin and then she was like ah so I was
like Lenin I have to show you my butt
crack and she was like why and does it
have not been at work and I was like yes
so we love it I need to know if I need
medical attention she and I did it and
when it was just like yeah you need to
go take care of that she did and it
turned out she just was wearing her yoga
pants too much hey lesson learned lesson
learned
[Music]